what's going on guys this is rob and we
know from she-hulk that seemingly the
marvel cinematic universe is setting up
for planet hulk and potentially world
war hulk and we know that because at the
end of episode number two or at least
towards the end bruce banner was on the
sakaran ship and was presumably heading
back to sakaar i don't know where that
[ __ ] would be taking him beside zakar
maybe there's just a really good chinese
buffet out there in space somewhere but
the question that i imagine a lot of
people are asking is that if we are
getting planet hulk in world war hulk
what is this going to look like right
what is it going to look like how's it
going to unfold in the mcu and that's
what we're going to be talking about
here so the idea when it comes to planet
hulk and world war hulk for those of you
guys who aren't familiar with this story
i'll give you guys a super stripped down
explanation if you do want to know about
the whole story arc and how it unfolds i
will link to the comics explained
incredible hulk playlist which is
basically a playlist full of videos that
cover all the greatest incredible hulk
stories ever told but the way the story
originally played out here is that you
had bruce banner who was tricked onto a
spaceship by marvel's illuminati the
intention was to send the incredible
hulk to a world that was exceedingly
peaceful because it was believed that
the incredible hulk's inherent violent
nature and his unpredictability made him
a danger to really everybody on earth
the problem is that the incredible hulk
flew through a gravity well ended up on
sakhar and through a series of events
basically became their gladiatorial
champion helped to overthrow the
existing leader of the planet called the
red king basically ended up marrying a
woman named kaira had a child and then
the way that the world war hulk story
picked up is that while he was on sakhar
the ship that initially transported him
there was nuclear-powered when it was
detonated or at least when it exploded
it led to the death of kiera and most
everybody the incredible hulk knew
except for his war bound but believing
that the illuminati were the ones
responsible for it in the sense that
they're the ones who designed the ship
he came back to earth and then started
targeting each member of the illuminati
starting with black bolt because he
sucks and then going through everybody
else ultimately trying to create a
gladiatorial contest that would have the
members of the illuminati fight each
other to the death this eventually led
to a superhero who has not been
introduced to the marvel cinematic
universe yet his name was the century
basically stepping in and then fighting
the incredible hulk seemingly to a
standstill while iron man activated
satellites at his disposal which
essentially depowered both the century
and the incredible hulk when i say
depowered i mean sent them back into
their normal human forms and that ended
the story or at least it did until we
got to heart of the monster hulk where
the incredible hulk was so strong that
he was basically punching holes in
reality which was pretty crazy he was
breaking the dark dimension the
dimension of dormammu it was pretty wild
but the question that we have to ask
here i haven't said all that the
question asked here is if the marvel
cinematic universe is going to give us
planet hulk in world war hulk will we
get a faithful comic adaptation in the
mcu and the answer to that question i
think is a resounding no just because of
the fact that the pieces that you need
to make that story work are simply just
not here for example there is is no real
indication at the moment that the
incredible hulk is a clear and present
danger to anybody on earth at least not
since the events of uh avengers end game
right so the incredible hulk and bruce
banner basically emerging to become
smart hulk he's a gentle giant he's a
cool guy who does his own thing we seem
to be past the days of like avengers 1
when it's just a rampaging hulk running
around doing things there's just
collateral damage and no one knows what
he's going to end up doing next so that
sort of removes that part of the
equation the other part of this equation
is the illuminati there's been nothing
to indicate that they exist in the main
marvel cinematic universe in 616 in the
mcu they might it could just be that
they're just operating behind the scenes
and we simply haven't seen them yet but
the reality here is that even if that
was the case it still goes back to our
first point that the incredible hulk
hasn't really done anything to indicate
he is a legitimate threat to everybody
the only exception to that being during
the events of age of ultron when he was
manipulated by the scarlet witch and one
on a warpath but i think that could
genuinely be accepted by most anybody in
the superhero community as being an
exception to the rule it's not the
normal fair that while the incredible
hulk can be unpredictable and the
incredible hulk's rage is one of the
more concerning parts of his character
it's not as though we've seen any
stories where the incredible hulk just
flipped out in some random city and just
killed like 300 people we haven't really
seen that yet but the incredible hulk's
rage and his anger and two degrees
unpredictability has largely been
confined to the battlefield so he's kind
of controlled chaos to a degree and so
sure the illuminati might say well you
know yeah he's control chaos but what if
we lost control of that it would seem
just a bit of a stretch if you can
really call anything that in comic book
movies but it would seem like they're
sort of forcing the plot so what i think
would actually happen here is i i don't
think that an adaptation of planet hulk
and world war hulk from the comics would
be introduced to the mcu there are a
couple big reasons for that leaving out
the stuff that we just talked about one
of the first reasons is that the planet
hulk story has essentially already been
told it wasn't told exactly as we know
it from the comics but by all standards
of measurement it was basically told
right it was thor 3 ragnarok the
incredible hulk landing on sakhar the
incredible hulk becoming a gladiatorial
champion thor was basically a stand-in
for silver surfer in the comics or beta
ray bill in the animated film of planet
hulk but basically he was like the heavy
hitter the big guy that we all know that
the incredible hulk fought the red king
from the planet hulk story was basically
replaced by grand master in the film
but the incredible hulk contributed to
removing the grand master from power and
so it's essentially the planet hulk
story what we're seeing here is kind of
a reprieve that instead of events
unfolding in the mcu the same way they
did in the comic which is that he stays
on that world until things pop off and
then he comes back to earth pissed off
that he basically left he ended up just
kind of detouring back to earth we got
all the events of infinity war and
avengers in-game and now we're back to
sakaar again and so what i imagine would
happen here or what has happened here is
that on the planet sakaar without the
grand master it is a leaderless place
that's fallen into a state of chaos
either that or it's just a giant power
vacuum and you have all these petty
warlords and strong men who are vying
for power but the reality is that
because the incredible hulk was the
gladiatorial champion of the people of
sikar he's the one they want he's the
one they want to rule them because
honorable combat seems to be what they
what they respect the most and so that's
why they've been trying to retrieve him
and so what you're going to get here is
basically world war hulk that's going to
be on sakaar as opposed to it being on
earth now i could easily see things
unfolding in such a way to where someone
had seized control of sakhar they're
ruling it and maybe it is the red king
that we know from the comics that bruce
banner's gonna go there he's gonna help
topple that guy and then he's gonna
realize hey earth already has a hulk
they've got she-hulk they don't need
another hulk i'm gonna stay here and do
my thing right he might even tell
she-hulk that right like you're the hulk
of earth you stay there you do your
thing in the episode in episode number
two they already kicked around the idea
of her being an avenger right so
possibly replacing the incredible hulk
on the avengers team so that allows that
really kind of lays the field open for
him to go do his own thing so he decides
to say on sakhar and that for whatever
reason maybe the red king is not
officially defeated or whoever that
villain is maybe they're not killed per
se they end up coming back in some
capacity and they wipe out the
incredible hulk's family or something
like that and that's when you get world
breaker hulk that's when you get this
instance where bruce banner kind of
looks around and it's just like this was
my shot at happiness i've lost natasha
i've lost betty ross i've lost this
person you know cair whoever it was and
just all that pain and all that anguish
from all that loss just comes to a head
this could also be an instance because
this is a question that we never got
answered this could be an instance where
this is the vision that the incredible
hulk saw when he was taken over by the
scarlet witch in the age of ultron
because remember we never found out what
bruce banner saw we found out what
everybody else saw but we never found
out what banner saw we just know that
whatever it was he saw was enough to
just send him into this uncontrollable
rage and that was basically it as a side
note i kind of hope that like he saw
himself becoming maestro because i feel
like that would just be a phenomenal
story to do in the mcu but it'd be very
easy for them to sort of bring that
unanswered question back and bruce is
like you know oh my god you know this is
what i saw right and just losing it
right all that pain and all that anguish
over the course of his life that he's
basically been suppressing because his
character arc over the course of the mcu
has been suppressing the pain and
anguish of loss that it all just boils
over and he just snaps and just becomes
world breaker hulk and then it all goes
nuts from there and maybe they have to
call other people in like calling the
avengers to basically help deal with
that or maybe she-hulk has to fight him
or something along those lines i'm not
really sure exactly how that would go in
fact let me know how you think that
would go right if the events of world
war hulk basically take place on sakhar
and there's no one there to stop world
breaker hulk who do you think ends up
being the person or persons to stop him
do you think it's the avengers do you
think that's a great time to like bring
in the silver surfer because goliath
just wants to consume that world and
like that's how galactus and the surfer
are introduced is like basically world
breaker hulk fights the silver surfer
let me know what you guys think in terms
of who you think might appear but that's
my thought right that's my thought on
the plot and on what we'll see with
regards to uh to world war hulk in the
mcu i think it'll basically be kind of a
continuation of what we saw during thor
ragnarok and the incredible hulk story
arc on sakhar and then it'll ultimately
wrap up what comes of his character i'm
not entirely sure the incredible hulk is
too popular of a character i think to
kill off so i imagine they'll end up
bringing him back in some capacity and
things will just go forward from there i
have no clue but again this is just sort
of my theory that i'm throwing out there
but as always let me know what you all
think i mean i never have to ask you all
to punch holes in my theories you guys
do it anyway but let me know what you
guys think
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace